yeah hello and welcome to this video and
yeah this is a pure experiment and I
have no idea what - will come out of it
so what I'm doing is playing stockfish
on HS and it has level 1 to level 8 and
I have no idea how strong that is I just
want to find out I'm starting with level
one I suspect that I can beat that
but we'll see and then see how yeah how
high I can actually switch that so you
can go into the tone and to take the
fall porn so I'm getting this pawn I'm
playing three plus two so it's a it's a
blitz time control with some increment
see five looks very dubious I can take
b7 is there reason not to take that no I
don't think so okay 22 I guess so a
little bit a little bit irritating is
the whole thing if I go is free should
win some stuff right the shocking move
but I think it just plays badly all
right
the the computer just plays really badly
so I can just take everything I should
have saved the Queen right okay I'm just
a piece up I'm completely irritated by
what to compute X to it yeah yeah
probably people who know what this level
making fun of me now that I play
stoppage-time on but I had no idea how
good or bad that is and they did it
seems to be pretty bad so I'm a Pisa
the computer is basically playing every
move instantly then we've got more stuff
and is it a chick made somewhere here
yeah we should
okay fine mate okay so we learned that
level one isn't great yeah so we're
going to up that a little bit play with
the Machine and yeah probably I can skip
for a couple and let's go for yeah let's
see what's office level four can do for
you
d5 slide is strange
okay I'm gonna take that Center okay
there that level also place some more
strange oops
what's that so it gives me a piece okay
level four is also really bad so hey we
know that I can up that go on wow that's
really good we said really better than
level one I really feel like it oh wait
Bishop a3 is actually trapping the Queen
so shouldn't do that
Bishop c4 is close to winning the Queen
again I can just take and play Knight b3
or others chickens also looking quite
tempting but you will need was the fruit
and I can take this for Lukey one mate
okay never force also will not explode
very strong and it seems so do I have I
really had no idea
so people are requested that I should
play against computer a bit so why not
let's go to level eight and and see if
this is an opponent that the kids that
gets tough to play this is a thing of
taking a bit of time Knight f3 years
uncommon here not sure why
okay so I actually cannot go g6 now this
is a little bit a little bit of pudding
this should be funny normal okay and the
thing is if I donate c6 sd5 this looks
quite annoying okay yeah and now Knight
to c4 or not probably not 27 not to see
am c8 the idea would be to bring it
later to e7 but I need to cover 85 again
I would like to play b6 in this position
but maybe Knight takes d5 is actually
possible 95 85 25 they don't see how I
save the rook so nice F and b7 is
attacked okay I'm coming right up okay
96 I don't know how dangerous that is
well computer just prepares 9 to c7 but
I don't know is that that's such a bad
deal okay I need to get rid of that and
now 96 actually drops the blade a drop
sir this is t4 right hmm
so if I grab computer will take with the
pawn 90 folks 890 b3 doesn't work so
what's going on here do I somehow get at
the pawn 98 it looks it looks a little
bit weird
yeah I wonder if I should go 94 yeah I
saw that i boosters but I felt that it's
still a reasonable position maybe that's
wrong
again it is reasonable yeah can I take
it unfortunately
so easy for watching to window just
pushes everything now and just made
hundred seven stupid now okay okay so
that was definitely tough let's see is
that really a level that would beat me
constantly we'll see okay
ambitious play leading to some reversed
color Benoni maybe I should have come to
gone to a g5 but okay
I'm so reasonably happy with us getting
rid of the bishop is an accomplishment
in the end depending okay Quincy too I
guess
yeah he wants to or it wants to get
nitrous e5 that's very understandable I
can't play 94 here
Knight h4 you will go back that doesn't
lead to anything
yeah maybe it's done too much see five
this is the kind of thing where you
always feel like against the computer
and compute a little feud it like c5
[Music]
everything's going backwards yeah I felt
I might have some play now against the
center of it this is probably not the
best position I answer engine maybe four
as possible and computers just playing
move move move
okay that that was a very very terrible
game I can just take the three okay so
that we can resign safe all I had was
terrible
yeah I know sitting on since I'm been
only position that I hate anyway against
engine is probably not a good idea
this probably no one is actually quite
kind of okay but it's still not what I
love to play
okay so I hope to get a somewhat closed
position and then try to do something
against the engine in such a closed
position yeah now probably I don't
really have any use for the bishop on
before my castle and then maybe I don't
want to cancel quickly if I play society
my place before it could be a problem
only have two castle before
Wow
Wow so the ticket would be one doesn't
look good a5 is b5 197 and c5 so do we
close the position or not you can also
take and play 94 here and leave for got
some sort of counter play ok night 2 H 5
or taking NT 5 I don't like it for Queen
age 5 I guess
okay each 6,000 I do now I'm somehow I'm
hanging on but it's not a girl fun so
I'm not killed quickly at least but I
have the feeling that ignites well stop
happening 25 and the night will come
plea form or this movie and it's also
annoying might be six second probably 27
I think safe form for it takes a form
I do not even play 9700 stupid and a3 is
coming yeah you know that the engine is
not going to make a mistake okay Jen
that level is already pretty decent town
I guess what to do I still feel I should
be able to get some points I mean the
thing is flying instant moves I think it
probably depends a lot on the production
type with it gets extremely close they
still have some chances this is not a
bad system
the Kings Indian attack you sometimes
some but I'll get those snow attacking
positions when the computer is seeing
the danger a little bit late sometimes
you can get that so I'm going to smash
here now if it doesn't work okay then
that is just bad luck
so then creature fades just about works
let that sacrifice doesn't work here
because I look stupid 25 and 25 was
especially stupid I know I'm just a
piece down neckl let us complain you're
completely useless to try huh so how do
you get some something against the Sun
play extremely close again it should be
what will this nice and kind of ending
pull me out
we're under something terribly here yeah
it's already the tricky I didn't want
you to this from reaction
[Music]
g5s extremely annoying you can go to age
five maybe some oh hang on but it
doesn't throw up good okay so write a
form yet it's actually not a very
reliable square for this for this night
it's 95 is always on
maybe this great what the heck
and then and then friggin a for hanging
okay mm okay
yeah and it's stronger 47 okay okay so
lemonade is already impossible Samia I
think this is rather my problem then
this level being so strong but you don't
believe that is so strong this kind of
position is normally about fairly decent
chance against an enemy because it is
one of those again one of those creeping
attacks
maybe maybe go do something now in five
four pop shop jihad really I am 94 okay
this is
yeah it is this is the sole setup for
black is completely ridiculous but it
works because of those epic so [ __ ]
really [ __ ] yeah this is I don't
believe this one [ __ ] must be cracked
ready I'm a magic for this world that's
a problem so then I have to start with
this movie 'm otherwise I mean I know it
kind of doesn't matter with otherwise
this is a great position I mean I'm
really fascinated that the end it just
gives zero after not like this this
looks completely terrible for like take
book things anyway yet 94
it helps nights deform so ok so let's
try this again trying to go for some
time extremely close I know I repeat
myself but ok Queen a for maybe the
whole line was already rubbish
now I have to play Queen d7 first his
position is already lost almost is too
bad he six is not threatening anything
at all it's the problem
I don't I don't have any moves it just
tell the book see wallets and this sucks
I mean completely sucks
oh okay
pretty fast training actually can you
really do nothing against this can't
play the my normal repertoire this is
bad
as hh6 mmm how do you play this actually
and this one but I don't quite see the
point
and then actually do glue okay I can get
a drone oh okay
let's get on the scoreboard joy sir it
doesn't look all that bad considering
how this all this same how the results
were yeah I don't like this much against
an engine to be honest interesting it's
not as dangerous probably now I'm
getting killed him
thiefthief is dangerous really on I
don't have Bishop e6 as the problem as
if I was hanging
Knight f6 s d4
remarkable how bad this is already
okay that's pretty awful okay Knight f6
Bishop g5 looks really awful okay
and it's coming with before
unfortunately I only saw it now no and
this is coming like instantly great
great
yeah not fun money not the other things
against the human you you always have
some some slight hope beyond okay you
might do something wrong but you know
that the engine just will checkmate you
here you can basically resign it don't
see the precise book c8 is the main
thread can have somehow play openings
that give me chances I don't know
you can try to straight every place
super solid
alright cool c-5m below is that set a
big deal probably not a big deal and
then C 4 and C 4 and fortunately and
again special f4
yeah I can't play Bishop f4 again
great I'm sitting there and have no
active idea absolutely zilch now my
pieces are not active really not
and somehow this is still going on I
mean it looks bad but it's not not over
yet
I have no development assessing invitees
and night f3 is just sucks as g4 is
hanging eyes on tui tui em what a bad
portion lucky one okay yeah it's not
really fun to play against those things
[Music]
may I feel actually employed pretty
terribly so I'm not sure that I need to
use that bandit but it's pretty bad but
try the French defense again it takes
there's actually not a good not good
news computer usually place these kind
of things very well it is an open
position you fool
this is extremely lame maybe I can do
something here I mean not winning but
trying to hold the least weight and the
Queen trying to get to 85 just put some
pressure on the phone
I'm still teeth okay really okay
really if white can do anything here I
don't really believe it okay so we have
a draw here right what can I do
something no income and s is really
doesn't make much sense content
structure of the conjugation but I don't
think a local aged 500 500 is each file
is probably even absolute wrong so any
one to one at least I going to draw him
it's played on the opening he pushes the
pawn or it pushes on always difficult to
do it computer style I don't ever see
one usually I was hoping that the engine
would actually capture the move Queen b6
looks it's not a problem I can actually
do this okay Bishop g5 is where the
sacrifices don't work oh this one
so at the end of 94 okay so I have to
take with this
oh I didn't expect that a citizen
annoyance really years look T to
probably just okay I can still not hmm
not escape
hahahaha yes okay what is disaster any
somewhat open position there seems to be
a problem let's just close everything
down this is not that great I know
actually I know that one but maybe the
engine that doesn't really understand
this g4 business you never know
it isn't so bad how to do this now
prepare some prepare five it's not easy
to play and five as it turns out so I'm
getting rid of that and then - sure okay
and then I will be H for something new
very slow moves yeah okay so maybe I can
prepare f5 after all okay
or is there some other way to my nights
are not exactly positioned to threaten
all that much takes it interesting might
be six indirectly playing against this
yeah blowing g5 blundering geez friggin
five and there is also probably just the
game yeah Oh too bad
okay so maybe one more game then I've
got enough beatings for one one day I
don't know if people play against that
and there is a comparison I feel I'm
playing like an idiot but maybe this is
normal against this engine yeah we had
that night earlier this is usually
considered to be fairly decent anti
computer tier opening
because it is so close this is normally
considered to be help phone should be
some
okay
preparing before
Wow b5
surprising so this is all closed down
see second come on now Queen GeForce
actually a little bit of an issue
unfortunately as it opened up important
squares you 5 in C 5 this is why I don't
gotta trade and I cannot play 90 to
shoot this is what I relied upon
it's awful absolutely awful
[Music]
ninety-two this should take you form
ninety-two still Knight takes e4
yeah those are the kind of moves that
really really annoy um should I don't
want to do it get offended it all that
badly really it was probably just so bad
yeah okay one more and then I'm calling
it a day
how is that played t tonight each six
seven
did I made a mistake
I have to grin I hate like the French
yeah if it's some somebody plays it
right and always having a totally crap
position simply because I don't know
what to do and then I get discussions
sorry already completely and clay what
is the situation and those days no ideas
no threads tons of problems you have
even this which looks like completely
ridiculous is so good for white
[Music]
yackin can resign this already I'm just
getting to totally guilty on all those
pins I lost almost the same game couple
of games as couple of games go somehow
stood on my have two should be three
years coming and I cannot protect the
Kings soil as those games really make
you look like a complete idiot gem like
you have no idea about the game but
maybe after you can beat like 15 times
are you kind of lose your useless spirit
I don't know can we sing a game against
this this [ __ ] computer really how
to do it and I need something something
on theoretical
which is sir as you plainly mentioned
something extremely close in bowline
I'd age five and send these things they
they look a little bit annoying here
doesn't need to be decisive or anything
but it is not looking all that noise
yeah
and again you look like a complete idiot
maybe the time control is also too too
quick I mean oh this is a very dump down
computer and it's not like stop fish
running or four cylinders yeah they'd I
would lose every blitz game against that
is totally clear but I feel a bit
frustrated that some kind of young dumb
stock fish is also winning against me
every game
so we have the time I mentioned closed
position
the engine Provenza five
[Music]
this is more more innovating move than
anything great
[Music]
and they say ch4
I like to I like to play a five stored
there is each form
I know Dave let's still only have that
scram it's also something where you
would with these would think twice you
had a check here doesn't quite work but
then it didn't quite work is funny it
doesn't remove it all okay okay
long one more drive and then then it's
gone really one love someone somebody
watches this stuff means it's completely
boring as seeing the computer kicking my
ass
[Music]
it doesn't look all that bad actually
getting some
bb-because cause we're taking
it's always really concentrating it's
like move move move
and like it's everything is super
obvious and of course for the engine
there's nothing like obvious not obvious
whatever it just feels when you are
human it just feels incredibly
frustrating that this thing is just
dashing I'll go after move so now
yeah the engine can sometimes just move
the b-pawn is the thing yeah like this
and this one can take you for crap unit
from such a good position on the awning
and I was sitting here playing game
after game wasting my time but it is
probably the worst possible opening
against an engine and beyond caring
oh great
and okay help me down all right I'm
gonna get some some sort of ending yeah
I mean it completely sucks which I'm not
mated
yeah what's up okay
cannot take you to the for was Q about
whatever okay yeah that's really enough
I don't even know if I should happen
with this crap I mean you you just get
beaten senselessly
maybe people who hate me watch this
video and actually love it I don't know
yeah so I'm don't do that anymore
anytime soon yeah playing against this
engine